thank you
just look at those people no screens on
it mosquitoes annoying them it's bad
enough to be pestered like this during
the day but when Knight rolls around an
unscreened porch can really be dangerous
for that's when malaria carrying
mosquitoes are nearby searching for
their evening meal of human blood
now malaria is a serious health problem
in the South and to the affected
individual it means exhaustion and
sickness that may make him an invalid
for life
run down homes
with primitive household facilities
and unprotected children like these are
the results unless proper health
information on malaria is handed down to
everyone
here's how the Civic group at Sumter
South Carolina tackle the problem first
a local school teacher was selected to
attend training classes at Memphis
Tennessee
play a two-week course on the essential
facts about the control of malaria and
emanate the mosquito was conducted by
local state and federal Public Health
officials
of course the community leaders who
attended these classes couldn't expect
to learn as much as their instructors in
such short time
but when they were ready to return home
they did have a sound knowledge of what
they were expected to teach others
back at Sumter our health Educators
started out on her new job to pass on
information to the local Health
Department staff
as well as to all institutions in the
community
Civic clubs
and hospitals rich or poor regardless of
race or color the Educators spread the
message around
training films were shown as the one
viewed by this grains group of how
public health workers destroyed the
breeding places of mosquitoes by law
reciding this is a necessary operation
but an expensive one to the taxpayer
however it can be reduced if everyone
takes personal control measures against
malaria
information on the disease was also
passed on to the parents Teachers
Association in order to determine how it
should be introduced in the science
classes of the public schools
science teachers were given special
detailed instruction on malaria control
so that they would be prepared to teach
the subject properly
they also arranged field trips for their
students the nearby malaria infested
swamps where local Health officials
demonstrated the effectiveness of Paris
green dusting
and oil spraying
Mobile Public Libraries carried
literature to rural areas where malaria
control was most essential
also the science sections of oil public
libraries had excellent material on hand
the use of poster and window displays
helped to keep the people of the
community up to date on all new
information
clubs were formed by those people who
lived on farms and didn't have the
opportunity to get into town often the
members of these clubs assembled
periodically to listen to new methods of
combating the old problem of malaria
no group was too small to receive the
important information of the reasons why
people got malaria and how to avoid it
at the County Health Center the Layman
was given final precautions on how to
safeguard his home his family and
himself
when the health educator was certain
everyone had sufficient information on
malaria control she briefly summarized
these main points
put up window screens to keep out the
mosquitoes be sure and place patches
over all the holes in the screens see
that all screen doors are kept closed
and as an added precaution it is wise to
place a net over the baby's crib if
there are cracks in the floor seal them
see your doctor if you live in malaria
infested areas and suspect that you have
caught the disease your doctor will test
your blood and if you do have malaria he
will give you immediate treatment for it
spraying oil on the water surfaces of
your private fishing ponds will kill the
larva in their breeding places
or by sprinkling dusting powder of Paris
green as this woman is doing
and now that you've screened in that
front porch you can really relax without
fear of catching malaria
[Music]